[Music]
they're always long titles at Harvard
and I bring the book up because I'm
going to be making a quick set of claims
that will sound unsubstantiated so I
just want to see you the thick number of
pages that are there to confirm what I
what I want to say and I think that I'm
going to be reiterating things that
people have already said today and
there's a good reason for that because
there is a core problem at the center
most people today understand that their
nuclear weapons are incompatible with
democracy incompatible with governance
incompatible with civilization and I'm
just going to be focusing on how
literally it's the case that they're
incompatible with governance if you ask
people if weapons are uncover Noble most
people will answer yes in one of two
ways first they're on governor bull in
the sense that they're subject to
oxidants and max is going to be talking
about that more later today but there
are scores of examples the French and
British submarines that collided under
the ocean nuclear submarines collided
under the ocean the time when we had six
live nuclear weapons just a few years
ago sitting on a tarmac for over 30
hours in the United States without them
being protected the moment when we
accidentally sent missile triggers to
Taiwan when we were supposed to be
sending them helicopter batteries who
could go on and on and the fact that any
may thing is subject to accident so you
don't want to have something which in
the event of an accident is going to
kill millions of people
is certainly one of the ways in which it
son Governor bull the second way in
which everybody would agree that it son
governor ballif we hear all the time
about rogue states might get one hackers
might get one terrorists might get one
that is that an illegitimate Authority
might get
one and that again is a very realistic
worry earlier we heard about the f-35
that the Air Force wants which is a 90%
digitized plane that is made to deliver
nuclear weapons but that f-35 was hacked
into just a few years ago and it was one
of 18,000 hacking incidents in the
federal government in that year alone so
yes
the fear of a rogue state is very real
the fear of a hacker is is very real the
the problem though with this language is
that by focusing on what we all call
illegitimate appropriation of nuclear
weapons hackers and rogue States and so
forth we leave out or we give the
impression that there could conceivably
be any legitimate form of nuclear
Authority and there simply isn't so I
think that we need to educate our
friends and neighbors about the fact
that nuclear weapons are deeply
radically incompatible with governance
in this sense that there's no way in
which the kind of situation that Joe
just described could possibly be
compatible with governance imagine you
are in a political philosophy course and
you're looking at different forms of
governance here's our stock recei here's
monarchy here's democracy and then
someone says oh here's another form of
governance we don't quite know what to
call it but it allows a tiny handful of
men and I do mean men to launch weapons
which will bring about millions and
millions and millions of deaths we know
that the recent figures on nuclear
weapons show that if only 1/100 of this
current arsenal is used 1/100 of the
current arsenal is used 44 million
people will die in the first few hours
and 1 billion in the first month and
that's if a tiny fraction of those are
used this graph is one that I think is
very important I think it's one of the
best ones maybe because it shows what
Jonathan was showing earlier that the
majority of weapons and on a year
earlier it was even clearer the majority
is
weapons are controlled by Russia and
United States despite the fact that we
hear endlessly about North Korea North
Korea has under 1 under 10 nuclear
weapons yes it's a danger a very great
danger but look at what they're looking
at when they look at us
North Korea in the 1995 International
Court of Justice case went to the court
pleading with the court to have nuclear
weapons declared illegal not reported in
the United States North Korea was the
only nuclear country to step forward and
support the international nuclear ban at
an early moment not reported in the
United States and so forth so I don't
mean to become the apologists for North
Korea but lessons in asymmetry what are
we asking the North Koreans and the rest
of the people of the world to look at so
it's crucial that we understand
especially now the bulletin of Atomic
Scientists has moved that clock forward
to two and a half minutes before
midnight it's crucial to understand the
way in which the nuclear weapons are
radically incompatible with governance
and while you can address that through
international law you can also address
it through national law as the marquee
blue bill does but let me just give you
a little bit more of the framework for
that our Constitution the key features
of our Constitution are two provisions
that put brakes on going to war one was
article 1 section 8 Clause 11 the
requirement for congressional
declaration of war we have not had a
legitimate congressional declaration of
war since the invention of nuclear
weapons because you can't have these two
things together and given the fact that
they're incompatible we've chosen
nuclear weapons and we've allowed the
requirement for constitutional
declaration of war look like a piece of
detritus that we can throw in the trash
over there the other the set other break
which I won't go into but I'll be happy
to go into it a later time is the much
misunderstood Second Amendment the right
to bear arms which does not exist
primarily
as an individual right to protect me
against criminals or you to go to a
hunting club it's a distributive right
that's like taxation like the electoral
vote that says however much injuring
power we have however much injuring
power we have it is going to be equally
distributed among all of us so that I
will oversee my piece and Jonathan will
oversee his piece and each of you will
oversee your piece and only if we can
all be persuaded that that foreign
country over there deserves to be
injured are we actually going to go into
them
we're not like infantile disabled people
who have been morally disabled going to
turn on the television to watch our
fellow human beings be injured we have a
say over it that's what the right to
bear arms meant as I can tell you in
more detail I will run out of time so
let me just say that the thermonuclear
monarchy compares the five times when
we've had a legitimate congressional
declaration of war with the many times
that presidents have come close to using
a nuclear weapon and I look in
particular at the at the Taiwan Straits
crisis in 1954 and the Berlin crisis in
1959 when President Eisenhower
considered dropping a nuclear weapon on
the Taiwan Straits and then in 59 on
Berlin they could not be more different
one is a model of deliberation of
testing of saying does this foreign
people really deserve to be injured and
the other is a kind of incoherent jumble
of sentences where there's no clear
thing that people are voting on and
there's certainly no dissent and there's
no active voting
presidential councils can do a lot of
things but they cannot do oversee our
entry into war because it's not a
deliberative body it's a standalone
individual person the right to bear arms
again I can elaborate this at length but
it is actually a very huge magnificent
amendment that has fallen into disgrace
and by the way that's not accidental
just as the constitutional requirement
for a declaration of war has
and trashed the right to bear arms has
been made to look ludicrous in the
nuclear age because these things are
incompatible and yet if we bring them
back they will make nuclear weapons look
ridiculous so let me just quickly say
that that something that that joe said
which is the marquis lou bill takes this
the the requirement for congressional
declaration of war and simply remind the
world and our own country that we have a
constitution and that it first launched
a first strike by the president actually
is wildly incompatible you can follow it
by just putting into google HR 669 which
is the little verse the ted Lieu in the
house version of it and if you look at
the tab there it gives the number of
co-sponsors in the house which is
presently 32 and then this says and the
Senate is currently five and we have a
lot of work to do because Massachusetts
the Marquis is one of the sponsors of it
our other senator is not yet a sponsor
of it and in she is now I went yesterday
[Music]
well this is a major step forward and
maybe you'll correct me on the house I
was about to say that we only have
congressman McGovern right now we're in
California there are at least 10
representatives but maybe we'll learn
that somebody else has just signed
another reason to be optimistic is that
the New York Times which I don't think
of as a body that that is there to
educate the public about nuclear weapons
maybe I'm wrong but I don't see them
doing a lot of work they had an
editorial in favor of the Marquis lieu
bill that's all the more amazing because
the Marquis Lou Bill is a longshot it is
the most pie-in-the-sky piece of
legislation but the New York Times on
February 5th did an editorial saying
Marquis Lou bill yes and another reason
to feel optimistic is that 500,000
people have signed a petition saying
it's got to be
past so I would just amount of time so I
would just say that if this seems like a
trivial piece of legislation it's
because our Constitution has been made
to be seem trivial it has not just the
force of hundreds of years behind it and
remember Thomas Paine said that the
American Constitution is to governance
what the alphabet is to what the
invention of the alphabet is to to
language and if if there were more time
and I do it in the book if you go back
and look over centuries to this idea
that a social contract has at its heart
certain break certain impediments to
going to war that have to be lifted and
tested before you ever injure a foreign
people so I'll stop there thank you yeah
given the way Congress basically rolled
over and endorsed Trump's illegal
unconstitutional missile attack against
Syria can you say a little bit more
about why lifting up Congress's
magnificent role is something that we
should be doing right now right and
again this is this is a terrible problem
of circularity Congress has been
infantilized since it had the the
declaration of war taken away from it at
the end of World War two it has it has
become a clownish operation book after
book has come out saying Congress is
dead or saying that Congress has
forgotten how to operate and that's true
there's lots of evidence of it but if
you it's because it's lost its major
piece of work that it's forgotten what
to do it thinks that being an impediment
force the Constitution was not designed
to have Congress be an impediment to
lovemaking or an impediment to going to
the library or an impediment to getting
a doctor helping you and yet Congress
seems to think that it's got an
impediment role to sanctioning federal
federal appointments and so forth no it
has one impediment role role impeding
injuring people because that's what the
social contract is made to do so it's
circular people could sometimes people
have
the Saint that what you just said about
Congress people sometimes say about our
population they say you want to trust
the population when we can look at the
idiocy of the population having done XY
and Z it's circular
now that the population has been
infantilized now that we have no voice
and whether we go to war we've forgotten
what it is to deliberate and I don't
mean the people in this room who by and
large do deliberate our thinking our
watching but many many of wonderful
smart people aren't and I'd like to cite
this statement by Gandhi you can wake a
man who's asleep but you can't wake a
man who's pretending to be asleep and
right now people are pretending to be
asleep and you know if even a small
weapon is used there will be people in
this in the streets and they are
outraged and I'm in my imagination I say
to them just sit down and be quiet
because your outrage will do nothing now
the injuries have been done and we can't
undo them it's now before the injuries
occur that we have to awaken people I
[Applause]
think that's very well deserved applause
I wanted to make sure to do that thank
you very much it's a great great
presentation and I saw your work and I
think it's really really impressive
there's another academic writing on the
issue of nuclear weapons and democracy
who's in the UK Nick Ritchie University
of York and both of you are inspiring
and inspiring the work of those outside
of the US and I wanted to reflect that
back because there's a move there's
there's a big push that there's a sense
of democracy that has returned to the
nuclear weapons debate by what you
briefly mentioned that overwhelming
majority of nations that are working to
now make nuclear weapons illegal and I'm
wondering you mentioned it really
briefly sorry I'll get it
you mentioned it really briefly but I'm
wondering if you've thought about this
and how that kind of might sort of
bolster those discussions that take
place here
the nuclear band yeah yeah I mean I
think that the national and
international are good counterparts
sometimes I say if you want to walk up
the side of the building you can only do
it if you have two surfaces and in part
the the interplay of the International
and national the National has been put
aside the International has also been
put aside as in that 1995 ICJ case but
together I think that we can bring
pressure to bear and I wanted to say
that because I usually do say this and
you're not here and so now I want to say
it while you're here that when I speak I
normally say that part of the ways the
the uncover nobility of nuclear weapons
is clear is that it's taken away our not
only our right of self-defense but our
right of mutual aid and your report on
what would happen if Rotterdam was
subjected to even a small nuclear weapon
is one I always cite about the
impossibility of mutual aid we we have
not only lost our ability to fend
ourselves but my ability to support and
help and heal you and yours to help and
support me and that is tragic so thank
you for that report
[Music]